اسعد الله اوقاتكم بكل خير نحييكم الى
بانوراما نناقش فيها هذا المساء
كيف تنفي صلتها بتفجيرات نور ستريم بعد
تقرير امريكي يتهم جماعه اوكرانيه والكريم
يصر على
من يقف وراء التفجير يعني نحن ملتزمين زي
ما قلنا احنا ملتزمين انه نحن ننفذ
قوه الدعم السريع السودانيه ينفي خلافه مع
الجيش ويصر على انتقاد قاده يقفون ضد
الانتقال المدني ما عمق الخلاف وما ابعاده
وفي ملف النقاش الثالث نساء افغانستان
الثاني عشنا في الدوله الاكثر قمعيه
ونظيرتهن في ايران لسنا بافضل حال لماذا
توجه هذه الانظمه او توجه غضبها على
المراه
ونحييكم الى نقاش الملف الاول ليس لنا
يدون في الامر هذا النفي جاء على اللسان
وزير الدفاع الاوكراني ردا على تقرير
نشرته صحيفه
تضمنت ترجيح مسؤوليه استخبارات
مجموعه اوكرانيه عن الهجوم الذي استهدف في
سبتمبر الماضي خطوط انابيب غاز نورس
المعلومات الاستخباراتيه الجديده افادت
بان جماعه مؤيده لاوكرانيا يرجح انها
مؤلفه من اوكرانيين او روس نفذت الهجوم
على خط الانابيب الذي يصل الغاز الروسي
الى المانيا لكنها نفت وجود دليل على تورط
الرئيس الاوكراني او كبار مساعده في هذه
العمليه ولكن المتحدث باسم الكرملين
الافتراض الامريكي بهجوم ارهابي لمجموعه
ان المعلومات الاستخباراتيه الاخيره بشان
الهجوم تفوح برائحه جريمه هائله التصريحات
الاستخباراتيه الاخيره لمسؤولين امريكيين
اعادت الى الاذهان التغريده التي كتبها ثم
حذفها وزير الخارجيه البولندي رادوسلاف
سيكورسكي
التفجير وتضمنت صوره لتسرب الغاز من احد
زي تلك الانابيب وعلق عليها بالقول شكرا
امريكا
السادس والعشرون من سبتمبر تفجير خطاي
نورت ستريم واحد واثنان
سبتمبر 2022 اوكرانيا تتهم روسيا بشن هجوم
ارهابي على الخط انابيب الغاز نورديستريم
واحد واثنان لاثاره الذعر في اوروبا
سبتمبر 2022 روسيا تتهم وعشنت باستهداف
خطي نورتي ستريم اكتوبر 2022 روسيا تتهم
بريطانيا في تفجير خطاي نوردسرين
فبراير 2023
تقرير صحفيتهم واشنطن بالتورط في تنجيد
ستريم بمساعده دوله اوروبيه البيت الابيض
يرد هذه المزاعم كاذبه وموسكو تطالب
بتحقيق دولي
نناقش هذا الموضوع مع ضيوفنا من موسكوي
لنا المستشاره السياسيه في مركز الدراسه
الدوليه اهلا بك
ومنكو مستشار وزير الخارجيه الاوكراني
اهلا بكم ضيوفي الكرام واسمحوا لي ان ابدا
من موسكو
معكنا نحن امام روايتين مختلفتين
متضاربتين تماما ففيما نيويورك تايمز عن
معلومات استخباراتيه تتحدث عن تورط
مجموعات قد تخدم مصالح
روسيا روسيا في المقابل تقول بان المتورط
الحقيقي وراء هذا التفجير هي واشنطن حضرتك
كيف تقرئين هذا التباين وفي اعتقادك من
المتورط الحقيقي في هذا التفجير الخطير
مساء الخير روسيا منذ البدايه قد اعلنت
بانه
تقف وراء هذه التفجيرات
وهناك عده اثباتات لدى روسيا منها غير
مباشره مثلا تصريحات بعيدا قبل هذه
التفجيرات بفتره انه سيعمل كل ما بوسعه
لكي ستنتهي اعمال هذه الانابيب فروسيا
فهمت هذا الشركه تهديد مباشر من قبل
امريكا بعدين من غير معقوله على روسيا ان
تفجر نفسها ان تقصف نفسها وان تفجر انابيب
تابعه لها ما هي مصلحه روسيا ممكن ان تكون
من وراء هذا الشيء لا توجد هناك مصلحه
ولكن من مستفيد من وراء هذه التفجيرات من
جديد امريكا ليش لانها بهذا الشكل قطعه
العلاقات الوطيده
اوكرانيه ويعلم ذلك في داخل اوكرانيا ما
الذي نفهم من هذا التصريح
[موسيقى]
فيما يخص
انفجارات نورت ستريم
قد تمت في شهر سبتمبر وحتى الان يعني امر
غامض جدا غامض جدا هناك بلبله هناك
تساؤلات
وهناك اتهامات بسيطه بما في ذلك اتهامات
تجاه اوكرانيا
[موسيقى]
يعني حسابات اوكرانيه يعني الناس الاوكران
والناصر الروس
واتهامات روسيا
واتهامات امريكا والى اخره الى اخره انا
اقول لكم صراحه
الان الان اوكرانيا لا تهتم كثيرا بهاي
موضوع
ولك روسيا تهتم سيدافين روسيا مستبسله
لتقديم دلائل تبرئها او تبرقها لماذا كانت
غير معنيه ما هذا كذلك يطرح سؤال وق ادر
ان ينتقد البعض كيف في هذا الاطار
بالنسبه لاوكرانيا الان هاي مساله ثنائيه
لماذا انتم لا تعرفون كيف انتم تعيش
وكل الثالث يوم تجيكم مئات من صواريخ
ومئات من مسيرات
الايرانيه يعني او روسيه شفت كيف
واستشهدوا يعني اشارات ومئات الناس
خلال اسبوع وخلال ايام
وهذا نشاهده
هذا شايفينه سيد جفين فقط هذا شايفينو
ونتابع تفاصيل ولكن هذا لا يمنع بان يكون
هناك مسلك لتحقيقات
روسيا طالبت لماذا ليست معنيه لم افهم
انا اقترح لكم
تناول على سبيل المثال كمان مساله الجديده
يمكن سماعته واكيد سمعتم
بان منذ يومين او ثلاثه ايام يعني مجموعه
من الروس المتطوعين
دخلوا روسيا مناطق روسيه من من اوكرانيا
يعني امشوا هناك عده عشرات الكيلومترات
والى اخره بعدين رجعوا الى اوكرانيا من
جديد هم يسمون مجموعه متتوعين
هذا الموضوع قد قد ولكن اسمح لي خلينا
نضبط نفسنا شوي وخلينا نبقى في اطار
الموضوع هذا مش موضوعنا نحن فاهمين انه
هناك هناك تفاصيل عديده تهم شان روسيا
لاوكرانيا ولكن موضوعنا اليوم هو وهذه
التفجيرات حضرتك تحدث عن امور اخرى ولكن
خليني خلينا نبقى في هذا الاطار سيده فين
لو سمحت
لماذا
الان ان الروس يمكن الروس سووا ذلك لماذا
الروس المتطوعين من اي بلد الاوروبي لماذا
هم ما قدروا ذلك ممكن ممكن ولكن
الشيعه مال كهذه تحتاج الى الخبراء
كيف يمكن ان نرد على هذا الموضوع ضيف يقول
بانه يجب ان يكون هناك خبراء للقيام بهكذا
عملي هو في الواقع تقرير نيويورك تايمز
تحدث عن ان هناك من
يعني وضع الغام على طول
وهناك مجموعات اوكرانيه ويمكن ان يكون
الروس كذلك مجانبهم لدعم واشنطن في هذه
الخطوه
الكلام ضيفكم من اوكرانيا غير مقنعه وكلام
افتراضي وبدون
المنطقيه
التسريبات
هي مقنعه اكثر برايه وهم يتحدثون عن
مجموعات اوكرانيه وهذا ملفت للنظر لماذا
الاستخبارات الامريكيه تسرب هذه المعلومات
الان عبر وسائل الاعلام
والسابق انهم ايضا عن طريق نيويورك اداه
عمليه اغتيال لداريا دوجنا بنت فيلسوف
الكساندوهن الشرير
وهذا
اعتقد هناك نوع من مشابهه في هذه
التسريبات كانه امريكان
ينتقدون الطرف الاوكراني في هذا الشيء لا
يشاطرون نفس الموقف
دون ان يبتعدوا عن هذه العماله التقريبيه
على فكره نحن في موسكو اليوم ايضا نحتفل
بعيد المراه انا اعيد متورث في الايام
الاتحاد السوفيتي ولكنني لاحظت لاحظت
مبروك ليكون النساء ولكنني لاحظت انه
اجراءات الامن في المدينه اليوم هي مشدده
وانا حسب معلوماتي مثل هذه الاجراءات
حتبقى في الايام القادمه ايضا كان هناك
معلومات انه روسيا تتخوف عمليات تخريبيه
في مدن كبيره وفي مدن اخرى في عمق روسيا
وهذا باستخدام طائرات مسيره وايضا
باستخدام مجموعات تخريبيه من اوكرانيا
وهذا ايضا يثبت بانه هناك
نيه من قبل اوكرانيا في
مثل هذه العمليات التخريبيه وامريكان يمكن
يعرفون هذا الشيء ويريدون ان يبتعدوا عن
هذا النحل سيجفين يبدو بان روسيا كما تقول
ضيفتي احرجت الجانب الاوكراني لانه كشفت
في الواقع بان اوكرانيا هي التي حاولت
القيام بعمليه تخريب هذه وحاولت ان تصعد
من خلال تفجير نوت ستريم
بوصايه او بدعم امريكي هذا شيء اخر ولكن
وكانكم محرجون وكانكم في ورطه
صراحه ما يعني الانابيب كانت غير شغاله او
هناك زي ما انا اتذكر هناك اربع خطوط من
خطوط غاز ومنها بس خط واحد كان شغال
والشغال بتقريبا عشرين في الميه
والان
اوروبا توقفت يعني ما تشتري غاز من من
روسيا فمين الان يهتم بنورك ستريم اكثر
شيء تبعد روسيا وطبعا المانيا لانه ساهم
يمكن يشتغل
وحتى لما كان هناك في حاجه
لاعاده تصليح او القيام بعمليه تصليح كانت
هناك مساهمه مع الالمان ولكن كان يشتغل
وفيما بعد كان هناك تفجير سيد جافين ابقى
معنا نحن نتحدث عن تفجير واحد واثنان
حضرتك تقول بانه هذا
هذه الانابيب لم تكن تعمل فمش مهم ان كانت
ان كانت تم تفجيرها او لا سيده الينا
سوفونينا هل لديك تعليق
طبعا اولا كان يعمل
على وشك ان يعمل وجزئيا الاعمال وروسيا
يتكبدت خسائر هائله من وراء هذا هذه
التفجيرات
وعلينا ان نتوصل الى الحقيقه روسيا ايضا
مزعوجه بالنسبه
لتحقيقات التي تجرى الان في دول اوروبيه
متعدده روسيا طلبت
مباشره بعد هذه التفجيرات ان تقدم هذه
الدول معلومات لروسيا ولكن هم لا يريدون
ان يتعاونوا وهذا تحت الضغوطات الامريكيه
اما في البدايه كانوا يلمحون ان هذا
التعاون ممكن ان يكون ممكنا فكل هذا مزعج
للغايه ولكن المزعج الاكثر انه نحن في
انتظار عمليات تخريبيه اخرى
على كل سنتابع هذا الموضوع اود شكرا لكم
جزيل الشكر
المستشاره السياسيه في مركز الدراسات
الدوليه ومن كيف يفهين ميكتينكو مستشار
وزير الخارجيه الاوكراني شكرا لك